este problema dice lo siguiente el
volumen de una caja es de 405 unidades
cúbicas el largo de la caja tiene x
unidades y el ancho de la caja tiene x
más 4 unidades y su altura es de 9
unidades en unidades cuáles son las
dimensiones de la caja y bueno me di 100
unidades cúbicas pero pueden ser
centímetros metros este kilómetros
cúbicos no lo sé pero son unidades
públicas porque estamos hablando de que
estamos en tres dimensiones porque
queremos el volumen de una caja así que
déjenme dibujarla y déjame poner lo que
tenemos tenemos que el largo de la caja
vale x así que voy a suponer que este es
el largo el ancho de la caja es x + 4
así que este es x + 4 y su altura vale 9
y además nos dicen que queremos saber
las dimensiones de la caja y que el
volumen de la caja es de 405 unidades
cúbicas entonces déjame ponerlo así no
no no mejor dejemos ponerlos y cuando
sacamos el volumen de una caja pues es
ancho que es x 4 que multiplica al aro
qué es equis y esto a su vez multiplica
al alto que es 9 entonces me queda x 4
por equis por 9 y esto tiene que ser
igual pues al volumen de la caja cuánto
vale el volumen de la caja el volumen de
la caja es 405 unidades cúbicas y lo que
tenemos que hacer es resolver esta
ecuación para x pero si te das cuenta lo
primero que quiero que veas es que esta
ecuación no está igualada 0 por lo tanto
primero voy a multiplicar 9 por x si me
quedan 9 x que multiplica x + 4 es igual
a 405 después voy a distribuir este 9 x
por el b x + 4 me queda 9 x cuadrada más
36 x igual a 405 y para igualar la 0 lo
que voy a hacer es restar de ambos lados
de la ecuación 405 recuerda que cuando
tenemos una ecuación cuadrática la mejor
forma de resolverlo es igualar la a cero
pero tanto menos 405 menos 405 y aquí me
va a quedar 0 perfecto es justo lo que
queríamos y del lado izquierdo nos
quedan 9 x cuadrada más 36 x menos 405
y bueno ahora como resuelvo esta
ecuación cuadrática si te das cuenta
todos estos números son divisibles entre
9 por lo tanto voy a dividir todo entre
9 pero cuántos 459 déjame hacerlo por
acá arriba para ver que nos queda de
dividir 459 cuál es el resultado 9 va a
dividir a 405 y dice así 40 entre 9 es
44 por 9 36 y sobran 4 entonces 36 y van
a sobrar 4 y bajó el 5 y después me
queda 45 cabe 5 veces de 95 por 9 45 y
si lo resto me queda 0 es exacta como
les decía entonces todo esto es
divisible entre 9 y esto es lo mismo que
poner 9 que multiplica x 4 no esperen
esperen esperen creo que hay una forma
mucho más fácil de resolver esto voy a
dividir todo entre 9 en lugar de
factorizar el 9 entre 9 entre 9 entre 9
y entre 9 es decir me estoy ahorrando un
paso porque si yo factorizar a el 9 lo
único que iba a hacer era tardarme en
dos pasos más así que mejorar de una vez
dividido todo entre 99 entrenaré se va y
me queda x cuadrada
que veas que estoy dividiendo todo entre
9 la idea es para simplificar las cosas
porque factorizar 9 x cuadrada más 36 x
menos 405 no se ve nada sencillo sin
embargo si divido todo entre 9 se ve
mucho más fácil de resolver esta
ecuación me va a quedar x cuadrada más 4
x menos 45 igual a 0 y por lo tanto para
factorizar esta ecuación tengo que
preguntarme por dos números los cuales
sumados me van a dar 45 sumados sobre
estados y la multiplicación de ellos me
va a dar menos 45 y bueno 45 lo podemos
factorizar en 45 y unam en quien más 3
por 15 pero 3 por 15 no me funciona
mucho y 9 y 5 595 porque sean 9 le
quitamos 5 a 5 le quitamos 9 me da un 4
y 9 por 5 me da 45 sólo hay que poner
uno positivo y uno negativo por lo tanto
me va a quedar x más 9 por x menos 5
igual a cero fíjate que el 9 tiene que
ser el positivo para que mi resultado de
mi suma de 9 más menos 5 me dé positivo
que tiene que ser 4
5 4 positivo en 9 x menos 5 es menos 45
y entonces tengo dos binomios igualados
a 0 y recuerden que esto quiere decir
que el primer binomio es igual a cero o
en su dado caso el segundo binomio es
igual a cero dos números multiplicados
de lanceros y el primero es cero o el
segundo es cero y después voy a resolver
para cada uno de ellos en el primero me
queda que x es igual a menos 9 en el
segundo voy a sumar 5 en ambos lados y
me va a quedar que x es igual a 5 y ya
con esto resuelve para x ya sé cuáles
son los valores de las raíces de esta
ecuación cuadrática x igual a menos 9 y
x igual a 5 ahora que x tomo podría
tomar x igual a menos 9 pero si te das
cuenta si yo pongo menos 9 en este cubo
me va a quedar que un lado vale menos 5
que el otro lado vale menos 9 mientras
que la altura vale 9 y eso está muy raro
porque no tenemos distancias negativas
yo no puedo hacer un cubo que tenga del
lado menos 5 o menos 9 por lo tanto esta
no es opción me voy a quedar con la otra
porque en este me van a salir resultados
positivos
4 549 el otro lado va a medir 5 y la
altura va a medir 9 y ya con esto tengo
las dimensiones de la caja son 9
unidades de ancho éste era el ancho
cinco unidades de largo cinco unidades
de largo y nueve unidades de altura y
vamos a comprobar que en efecto esto me
da 405 9 x 5 45 y 45 x 9 lo tenemos aquí
arriba es 405